I don't think everyone plays here or
[inaudible] [inaudible] at [inaudible].
On what? In your marriage? A
[inaudible] [inaudible] on blockchain
a or to the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
in the marriage, you create,
develop a massive department.
Neurology Maxim for new,
presented to the only level.
I don't feel they donate.
Don't cure happiness for
reliever. Uh, lift too. She wrote,
has lists to our direct collect the donee,
the three Lipemia Moodle,
the statistic,
previous unit [inaudible] risk or just
Kennedy's big data within a of Daniel's
innovation and technology.
Uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] come to me.
[inaudible] the opportunity.
Nouvelle uh,
key some places probably
meditate or 200 or more.
The lesson today with all the security
to the condition. Micrologic uh,
may two swing. You got Molly
different, more Hiscock exist. Uh,
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] tell
American the risk of socio postmortem
or
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
on a view of Smr the discrimination
[inaudible] pouring this state only
[inaudible] [inaudible] um, don't
see the opportunities. Risk.
Suppose the new well costume.
It's in
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] what have I the
[inaudible] [inaudible] to turn the
[inaudible] donut affliction is coachable.
Copayment on sleep affects [inaudible]
to fit a significant problem.
Me
[inaudible] [inaudible]
a [inaudible] platform.
[inaudible] [inaudible] platform.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
particular [inaudible] on
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
the [inaudible] keep, don't care. Um,
[inaudible] his own death. Uh, the,
the two buyers with city,
the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
on the many of our larger keynote
[inaudible] on the PC to see the person
dependent decision with this is your
neck cause as well,
when you were a pallet mortality,
she's Latif keep a phone in a
Porsche presynaptic. The technology,
it keeps [inaudible] or development
or of course, the placebo,
the development,
the universe.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] in
the DVDs or Ottawa party in [inaudible]
storage in [inaudible] told
the keystone regular motor,
assume in quite central governance,
they donate like extremely Tiguan
fillers or fix your success.
Usually they don't clear objective
to permeate city veritable model.
Fairly numeric, uh, kitchen. The phone.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] or a key piece.
A veritable might come a
redesign. Maxim coupons, twitch.
She brought that up.
She put plaza,
uh,
[inaudible]
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible],
uh,
soon collected on analyst.
They donate
[inaudible] [inaudible]
include leaves the Peller lumpy or
they donee Lotito regional or regional
because reading is, if they
look, look who data city Pomona,
the person key data centers are really the
[inaudible] [inaudible] what it nearly
will approve what you're a part of them
off at a [inaudible].
This is on a pretty
cryptic, Eh, uh, ski at
[inaudible] [inaudible]
he will party on gear.
Look like cultural they donate
is only [inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
or Sonia homie progressive.
More historic,
more [inaudible] pubic
ECOMM awfully Schiff.
[inaudible] I did
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
remove statistic save statutes.
The level of their own Italia
[inaudible] don't covet with this year,
the compounder, the many of descriptive
on prototype of what [inaudible] is.
April [inaudible] data [inaudible] data
[inaudible] portion whole assymetry.
[inaudible]
septics when they complete no
optimist with analytic new cities,
he does most of the foundry Malashenko
compile the, the technology it PA
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
liberal. The show happen more.
My statistic, uh, validate the Promo.
Descriptive [inaudible] prescriptive
with our way on exam kid [inaudible] by
example.
Peloton ponders RPD exemptions or
Lewis says [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] person.
What ad server or functions?
The cerebrum Slough
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] per component
moment to the prison complex,
which will be on [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] a normal,
the PSN say citizen Catterick your fiance
[inaudible] [inaudible] restaurant
[inaudible] statistics prescriptive and
exist. There's other PSA, a lotto.
It's in a pulmonary Vic to us if we
need to shift. Sure. Solid Wall. Yeah.
So teeth in the situation
came away. Uh, I say
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] is pain.
[inaudible] arithmetic on fats.
See the mouth upon the decisions on not
quotidian Pisco does that Rafini like
complexity,
the amount of animal protein [inaudible]
gone with the past [inaudible] profile.
The more Yan upon the decisions.
So they shows keystone were actionable.
It don't do equity statistics that
if new or smaller poison [inaudible]
mortalities for the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
marketing [inaudible] care.
Let me get to enable the big data with
a V in collect key. Explain ourselves.
I think the capacity to catch his from
head with it don't contaminate last
statistic.
Classic
[inaudible] [inaudible] goes
to the way a [inaudible].
Speaking of [inaudible] at
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] I
know now for Atlanta like normal and we
ended the VR.
Chris captive nominative
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] big data so you
can collect to can collect to to the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] poner leaders to
[inaudible] [inaudible] verite numeric
police [inaudible] sim collected the
principles of DNA and protein or fat
show's QT next to [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] is from [inaudible]
the bacteria [inaudible]
Los Gatos bid the farm.
Assume,
say she got [inaudible] Second Central
Devi Devi let truth because the farm we
detected because a certain melody,
but at [inaudible] a seller,
his own Pollock [inaudible]
presumptuous, uh, uh, the, the, that
tokenize the opportunity,
the is uh,
a little smarter.
Terrorism as a rescue.
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] um,
just to one on cash,
many consequences. [inaudible] tell note
he put it onto a piece. Come to a switch.
Spoons on [inaudible].
It should,
if you use my past excuse [inaudible]
who makes [inaudible] she puts on me
consult homey or that I
can collect the problem.
Keep us busy sequence or may come
in from the very tinny marriage.
You don't develop our hopper Kz mystique.
[inaudible] I love potion computers
from also kind of Equitas.
You a certain platform,
the music on [inaudible] a
[inaudible] [inaudible] system or from
a team called money smart contact the
blockchain, they don't really
on our [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] story
for Omni progressive on the situation.
Some in culture critic junior Merrick
mcclintic with Saas constructive study or
Komatsu quiz. The decision can use
effect to [inaudible] last your own.
So the finger pack or
Super [inaudible] swabbed.
Those in certain [inaudible] note they
don't come on is the more the decision
please.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
um,
drunk a series on Casa [inaudible]
may lack is trying to sell.
Do you LGP then encourage
possible to monitor, uh,
Sushi them or at Tom Polymedia for
component [inaudible] personnel.
Sit on text.
Keep [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] on
the website in directive on Catwoman
Council Casey delivery
sample Nivo Ipi Pisco,
yet the protect the form shipping's that
Yahoo's layer on the alarm don't do pay
and function.
The tokenization Provo in a religious
lesson keeps a prefab [inaudible] maxima
books on why
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
plus exists if you count
skinny woman nor secure
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] per the formality
of functional responsibility do tread
Montenegro Fuzzier [inaudible] from
collecting [inaudible] newsletter
newsletter,
their suits they donate for or somebody
more available on Panto then city posts
is on symptom the Vietnam.
All this wine in the fan declassified
like Neil's for failing the mandatories.
That's nonspecific.
[inaudible] assume a,
a sea of the path.
I will confirm when we are,
they put on [inaudible] and [inaudible]
incentive they have at the Resectr skid
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
concerns [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] regionality,
cardinal [inaudible] savoir [inaudible]
who sees a duty don't text too similar
and the diagnostic want to go in DC day,
Kevin on liver [inaudible]
Econ, et cetera. Uh,
but that's the diffuse in
from the soft power. The
[inaudible] [inaudible] is it has unique
or do the donkey electric Dijon and et
cetera.
[inaudible] Gong group.
We were going to say [inaudible]
this example by example.
Facebook
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and
emerged in the [inaudible] department.
Free flow of information.
So that way, uh, continuing
[inaudible] [inaudible] the conference
for the loss of the party opponent of at
the palm of our in Google knows the domain
controller [inaudible] it [inaudible]
the day. Uh, don't vote. [inaudible]
limits the tech actual more pecan
trees does it Asia Kumasi uh,
uh, I said uptick, um, in the
community pop or big data secure.
Don't worry. RCPD who do we collected
the DNA point Finelli determinant.
All the big data we collected.
If we determine the irrationality,
when did Jackie can call them
in a big data CBG, passive GRC.
PDC that time minimization.
[inaudible] yeah,
the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
personnel Kombu service.
Our croissant couldn't party.
Meaning they do nick ejaculated, pop,
ordinary scale, et cetera.
[inaudible] don't care.
[inaudible] they don't
understand. So that uh, the,
the [inaudible] speak to,
to see, um, strategic,
um, less social [inaudible] personnel.
Sick Yom Kippor in the definition.
So no more secrets.
One consider for tweeting donee
personnel soiree [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] do [inaudible]
he has a sibling or Radu the algorithmic
Ma and who simply on it that La socis
certain person that put out on the
democratic not to care. That palate
lecture certificate should prefer
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] number
[inaudible] skill or characteristic,
the big data Sipa,
her [inaudible] in focus.
I've been Brachia opensource support
contaminant or somebody cared about being
southern Virginia was
having done the personnel.
They don't put that data set on OT it in
the neck. That person that mocks acid.
So the foot efforts,
there's just a molecule
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] tomorrow.
Uh,
[inaudible] uh,
it won't cure consumer. This coming
Monday say is concealed weapon permit.
Uh,
the remo politician is not a,
not decorations come
down from 12 till fair.
The priest Prophet and send money
at all.
[inaudible] uh,
new [inaudible] media.
We see this positive.
The do the work is
[inaudible] the [inaudible].
Yeah,
we seal it.
Teach keeper for [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] privacy by design.
[inaudible] we [inaudible] on our moon.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
Sassy [inaudible] would be
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] march we came up hop
hardware platform in a pub
is one regulator in a pub is
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] technologic
[inaudible] as well. It could number one,
twice a day.
Teach kids.
What's your muscle loss
of the [inaudible] map,
particularly general.
Some particular motor denotes lead
the discrimination and go with Mitch
[inaudible] personality.
[inaudible] [inaudible] may levy
prevented on the personnel department.
Jerusalem
collected the,
the personnel songs
about Optune consulting.
[inaudible] [inaudible] survey of it.
Some promoter really are need to,
the [inaudible] on the [inaudible] was
a vapor that proves the [inaudible] new
hotel. [inaudible] also shoots
ujl a black box society.
The front pass Quirky Speak [inaudible]
segmentation or certain category is
sigma the machine. What the defense? Uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
Republican Amerigroup Pamela Barksdale
functional.
Some I go [inaudible] Google development.
They'll go read a search index.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
connect with function one says we were
written with [inaudible] with the second.
Is that fair?
It's [inaudible].
You could move the needle of functional
folks and monitors that are all like
extremely wet and the
[inaudible] the [inaudible].
So Dita I dog over [inaudible] [inaudible]
malfunction [inaudible] music cause
that's what [inaudible] meant.
The mania. Pure more concerns.
Mescaline is engineer again.
Didn't Sefton cluster associated in
southern party remotely do quizzes on
[inaudible] [inaudible] in this community.
Concern with me in [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] system
or for my songs as well.
Agriculture is a pinto to weigh a cab.
They don't cure the problem.
Secure [inaudible]
cause that's where the doctor who
upgrade the journey's not specifically
[inaudible] fake come a concept that the
silicone was that as you need more made
them
look at all the platform I call
[inaudible] [inaudible] the
four on Bitcoin Pannonia on
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] of while sitting.
He did not leave your proposition pretty,
pretty big.
Don't live a pathetic back in
[inaudible] two committee exists.
The packing list for national sick as
the, there's a fair, the fourth fee.
Scalor confirm the restaurant. Amanda.
That's just bizarre phenomenon.
Awesome. Um, uh,
[inaudible] was unable. Cool.
Um, she, she wants to do kitchen.
It was reputable shredders
to Marcello. So the, the,
the Google home care kpps he said
[inaudible] [inaudible]
John Ted. Don't care. Admin.
If care associates exited cloud,
for example.
[inaudible] at [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
Jericho
[inaudible]
is this past public?
The discussion keys for
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
the Lawrence Lessig code is low.
It very fine.
Silicone formatic [inaudible] decision.
So for Nivo Algorithmic, you can
prepare for axial Motif, concrete.
The decision like responsibility Cresco
sociality with [inaudible] public
[inaudible] platform,
he proposes that go Goldman
[inaudible] la function more
through our nurse has
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] more secure items
to, you'll develop. We see
this algorithmic keep up. Amen.
Determining Lot poppo faculty
that [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] competent
phantasmagoric may [inaudible] the
system.
Algorithmic autonoma we perform the
decision in the past prison concrete
possibility of it.
The new [inaudible] and function more.
I'm the head is on content of
functional democratic. Don't set on the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Palliser particularly
impacting on also sauce you're
going for, we will do to set the
path for nick more catalytic.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] key put that, uh,
um,
[inaudible] she did.
[inaudible] Santana was on the volley
middle.
Well,
you
put the
issue.
What else can I tell him?
[inaudible] in [inaudible] function
to figure [inaudible] where you buy.
If you have clear access, something
that's your horse or functionally fingers,
it was your son, gets it out and put
them on. This is a complex topic.
A buffer or have postage
associated credit scoring.
Shinoa [inaudible] swarm the a system or
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
continuing of Etsy and texts.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] more
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] so
predictive middle mania,
clamp tier with LMS senior Israel is
because [inaudible] doesn't get to go.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] may or not to
know when possible. It looks past comfort.
Let the fear that if he could this
statistic and we can very tickets where
numerics they, the continental
personnel on the comp. Optimal.
It could be predictive.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
liquid data secure with the past.
The power
[inaudible] [inaudible]
yes.
Yes.
Donald [inaudible] power
and you could shoot out to
fail protection. Uh, the jamboree. What?
I don't see fee [inaudible] yes.
Good.
She know
at all.
It takes and the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] over the nonexempt
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
great.
Yeah.
Only liberal shows the DPO,
the data protection of
[inaudible] organisation.
Certain situational exists [inaudible]
silica sand [inaudible] governance.
They donate like kill children.
America.
Leah Elix petition with the data
[inaudible] Sefton that you'd done pack.
No. Timo [inaudible] privacy
impact assessment [inaudible]
lastly,
the data [inaudible] or world perming
[inaudible] not deponent's the
organization who is killing the future.
The cemetery
right
at all.
Does anymore.
[inaudible] in cultural,
the numerical [inaudible] Eva,
Eva [inaudible],
the logging [inaudible] found your board
with this executive [inaudible] the
tunnels,
the [inaudible] a [inaudible] person
whom [inaudible] chief data officer,
a chief digital officer on campus.
[inaudible] [inaudible] the
[inaudible] looks upon in the, in the
[inaudible] [inaudible] a Sassy until
I saw 'em Laponia for you and you don't
hold the mathematical Boissiere Marinara
[inaudible] party Dubler [inaudible]
responsibility coming sell the
[inaudible] [inaudible] had the
bankruptcy for a also debilitated
[inaudible] [inaudible] responsibility
commercial. If [inaudible] Korea,
we could wind mathematic exists.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] a prominent Muslim
sequel say pharmaceutical equitability.
There aren't a pleaser swimmies on an
eloquent abilities. These young kids,
they don't Kesco sales
model accountability.
[inaudible] the accountability do that.
It seems to legal accountability months,
the discrepancies,
the deviations don't have a testimonial.
They nonconformity [inaudible]
responsibility or unpacking
Garcia and made the
complaints.
Popeye's text more scan the very
tablet simile to not really do is in
[inaudible] assault the school.
Aleks MCAP Mercato,
Ya hear me on level [inaudible] party.
DUPLO [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] the text,
he's key swiped peekaboo.
Told the set person each must be a
[inaudible] [inaudible] on the go.
Purchase a pair.
It's a very troubling or challenging
a Nokia
format on Pearl contexts are sycamore,
mathematic,
and yet they're haggling is exceptional.
[inaudible] the company. WBC
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Spotify.
If women with other parties of
tender naval proven upon which
leaders who just don't say the
[inaudible] don't own ecosystem.
Pascoe historic more. Yeah. To
draw a c comebacks. When I say,
could you check ecosystem is say that a
world garden and [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
ecosystem ecosystem now.
portability the donee since
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] data
[inaudible] [inaudible] he small
car look on as development.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Achy
job.
Is it
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] the notification.
Fido security
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] to lose it all.
Knowledge Ledge a
[inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah.
Uh,
sure.
This house and didn't say
to protections a straw.
I thought secure maybe long productive,
Levante
and receive the shorter
shoe
and the usual security.
Yep.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
application.
Territorial non-text don't Indian rooted.
We are rapid city government.
You've indirective open.
He definitely said Marla,
the parameds territorial
Okello the techs nervous.
A PK [inaudible] eh,
upheld.
We are shipping [inaudible]
important to the nonexempt.
[inaudible] was a very,
uh,
[inaudible] or some on this
[inaudible] open the techs,
the Sepik maybe that
associate American sheen.
Was he a effective [inaudible]
there's of the, the,
the ID service or the, the person
who sounded new, open the text.
Separate Cosi Yar shrink study retired.
We could pull out.
So I said the point of [inaudible]
on the [inaudible] c a.
Okay.
We are the tax skis.
Applique and [inaudible]
say [inaudible] I said,
I said you kept Parka,
but don't sell more vocal
veterinary turkeys to me.
I don't [inaudible] felt
with Atlantic to America.
Donita [inaudible],
California,
northern cal sappy care in
this position in particular,
or act certain, the city's
position on those certain controls.
[inaudible] peekaboo pyre fed
the profiling the person's
situation in your pen.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] he's a peekaboo,
uh,
or functional activity
or
awesome
[inaudible]
stage.
So she does
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] her class, uh, songs,
a new district,
the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] severity on deficits.
The complainants room key.
She don't ask,
but Emoji grotesque
Marshall puts in our memo.
Let's [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] discipliner.
So Jackie,
decoder tie of industrialists,
excuse Kimanti.
[inaudible] industrial reconnaissance.
Domo in the governance,
the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] component.
[inaudible] found the functional
[inaudible] who controls it?
Memes seems that Machista [inaudible]
difficile maybe that we couldn't control
statistic, but most of the most
ridiculous. A reservist for some
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] a
decision the way a delegate tags up the
second bulimic commercial.
Apparently the start commercial
coverage issue [inaudible] to come last.
Kampala,
privacy by design database design,
a design engineer or [inaudible]
demand upon the decision on a more
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
on Kijiji or sociology and philosophy.
Me
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and it plays
off the [inaudible] me [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible],
uh,
Lou Beckman Center on the hop.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] would be like,
treated usually philosophy.
[inaudible] stiffs
youngest film buffs introduce Garcia.
No,
but you think,
wow. You Jackie here.
That's okay.
Scott Volks
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] Wisconsin. Who? Uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] no sauce.
Andrea [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] on what?
Sociale you remember him?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] yeah. [inaudible]
push purity disciplinarity permit.
How the determination is
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
vocab without your ranking.
The zoo's tell Jewish.
I do the Torrance to draw in
Nevada [inaudible] which, uh,
at a DC stems from [inaudible] Mazda
[inaudible] participants on pathway.
We kept on the, the, um,
[inaudible] role or the concept.
He's only possible with a law firm.
That motto is
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
say [inaudible] apology.
They get worse. Men just among the
new shut the law firm. I want to the
[inaudible] concept,
the,
uh, the key to the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
we
had off tomorrow.
[inaudible] that's
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] so
what are our police has? Yeah,
they showed the Siki view your own dollar,
dollar jargon.
Command on a culture commune.
[inaudible] so cute.
[inaudible] gone. What? Mayor?
Who is that in a startup paths
[inaudible] unique on the Dev,
on the Internet, which cause literally
cannot do this condition. For example.
[inaudible]
do you notice small?
You Bobby
[inaudible] [inaudible]
new component by example.
[inaudible] who sounded the
[inaudible] [inaudible] I
found the [inaudible] control.
I did you feel on vocabulary?
[inaudible] minutes.
[inaudible] put up
[inaudible].